studie mit so vielen menschen solltest
du geschlafen haben erfolg am
weltraumbahnhof kourou und rolltreppen
studien das sind drei der fünf themen
enterprise bekämpfung von depressionen
in den usa in den usa aber auch bei uns
werden erkrankungen wie depressionen
immer noch zu wenig behandelt das liegt
zum teil auch daran dass depression in
der bevölkerung verhältnismäßig wenig
akzeptanz erfahren es halt irgendwie
keine krankheit daher wenden sie
betroffene oft auch nicht an ärzte oder
bekommen die falsche behandlung
diese situation wollen experten die sich
in der us preventive service task force
kurs usb sdf zusammenfinden jetzt ändern
sie wollen dazu eine landesweite studie
durchführen das rechtfertigen die
mediziner laut beiträgen im journal of
the american medical association damit
dass durch depressionen nicht nur der
betroffene geschädigt würde sondern auch
die ganze wirtschaft darunter zu leiden
habe rund 23 milliarden dollar würden
die us-wirtschaft der schaden durch
depression kosten es würden sich laut
den experten also lohnen so viele
menschen wie möglich zu screenen per
fragebogen wollen sie den zustand der
bevölkerung erforschen so könnten mehr
patienten geholfen werden sollte einer
der tests auf eine depressive erkrankung
hinweisen für manche leute seien
anzeichen einer depression nicht direkt
deutbar anzeichen können auch kopf- oder
rückenschmerzen sein und um die ausmaße
dieser erkrankung besser in den griff zu
bekommen fordert michael hayes von der
university of pennsylvania folgendes
zitat wir brauchen pflegedienste und
stationäre einrichtungen in denen
schnell und flexibel reagiert werden
kann wenn der patient nicht mehr seinem
behandlungsplan folgt oder die therapien
versagt zitat ende
klimawandel deutsche forscher nennen
neue zahlen überschwemmungen stürme
dammbrüche oder immer weiter schwindende
eisflächen all diese phänomene treten
immer häufiger auf der klimawandel
richtet jetzt schon gewaltige schäden an
und das ist noch lange nicht alles
experten prognostizieren schon lange
noch höhere ausmaße infolge des
klimawandels besonders wenn es um den
stetig steigenden meeresspiegel geht
dieser würde aufgrund der wärmeren
wassertemperaturen jedes jahr um rund
0,7 bis zu einem ganzen millimeter
ansteigen deutschen forscher zufolge ist
das aber nicht richtig es wäre sogar
viel viel mehr im fachmagazin
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences berichteten die wissenschaftler
von einem jährlichen anstieg von 14
millimetern also etwa dem doppelten als
angenommen die forscher kamen zu diesem
ergebnis als sie die satellitendaten aus
den jahren 2002 bis 2014 analysierten
als folge dieser entwicklung rechnen die
forscher mit noch stärkeren stürmen
addiert man die 14 millimeter mit dem
zusätzlichen anstieg der sich durch die
schmelzwasser menge ergibt käme man auf
einen gesamtanstieg von fast 3
millimetern volk am weltraumbahnhof
kourou am vergangenen donnerstag ist es
dem unternehmen arianespace intel satt
und der esa gelungen die erste ariane 5
rakete in diesem jahr vom
weltraumbahnhof kourou in französisch
guayana ins all zu schießen
der start verlief ohne komplikationen
die trägerrakete brachte einen
interessanten 29er
telekommunikationssatelliten ins all das
hatte lied ist eine neuentwicklung der
epic entschiede und die ist sehr viel
leistungsfähiger in der datenübertragung
als die vorgängermodelle und so sah der
erfolgreiche start aus das ganze video
findet ihr wie immer in der video
beschreibung
rolltreppen als objekt einer studie nun
ja diese studie hat es in london
tatsächlich gegeben und sie zeigt der
stadt sogar auf dass sie bald ein
problem haben könnte also worum geht es
also zunächst sollte man wissen dass
london immer weiter anwächst mit der
steigenden anzahl der dort lebenden
menschen wächst natürlich auch die
aufgabe deren transport von a nach b zu
regeln wenn möglich sollte das auch noch
umwelt schon funktionieren mit einer
rolltreppe befördert man die einwohner
zwar nicht zur arbeit und zurück aber
mit der u bahn und die erreicht man eben
auch über rolltreppen
britische forscher haben jetzt
herausgefunden wie man in möglichst
kurzer zeit möglichst viele menschen
runter zu einer u bahn station bringen
kann und das klingt erst mal absurd
rolltreppen sollte man dafür ausschalten
mitten im londoner zentrum in der hort
und station führten die wissenschaftler
ihre nierfeld experiment durch unter
einem feldexperiment versteht man eine
versuchsreihe die unter realen
bedingungen durchgeführt wird in der
u-bahn-station holpern wurde also nichts
verändert außer dass man die rolltreppen
abgeschaltet hat zwischen 38 und 39 drei
wochen lang wurden die rolltreppen
abgeschaltet und es zeigten sich bisher
dramatische ergebnisse 16.000 220
menschen wurden über die inaktiven
rolltreppen fördert bei normalem aktiven
betrieb konnten gerade mal zwölf 1745
menschen befördert werden mit funktions
und techniken rolltreppen konnten also
fast 30 prozent mehr menschen zur u bahn
gelangt kleiner haken an der sache die
rolltreppe müssten die personen
mindestens 1800 meter in die höhe
befördern oder nach unten müssen weniger
höhenmeter zurückgelegt werden würde der
mensch nämlich eher zur treppe tendieren
als zur selbstfahrenden treppe was aber
ist das problem dass daraus resultiert
das problem sind die aktiven rolltreppen
dem guardian zufolge müssten diese in 34
jahren rund 60 prozent mehr menschen
transportieren
da gibt es also an problemen
studie mit so vielen menschen solltest
du geschlafen haben
was also klingt ein bisschen bescheuert
aber laut der zeitung independent haben
sich die betreiber der britischen
datingseite discounters dot com
mit genau dieser aussagen beschäftigt
und eine studie darauf dazu
herausgebracht ja sie starteten eine
umfrage an der rund 1000 personen
teilnahmen und die fragen der umfrage
die ziethen schwerpunktmäßig auf das
sexualleben der teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer ab mit wie vielen personen
hatten diese bisher geschlafen welche
anzahl an sexualpartner und halten sie
für in ordnung also ab wie vielen halten
sie es für verwerflich das ergebnis der
umfrage 38 prozent der weiblichen und
ungefähr genauso viele männliche
teilnehmer nämlich 37 prozent nannten
zwischen acht und zwölf sexualpartner
und acht bis zwölf sexualpartner seien
ihnen zufolge auch natürlich die
optimale anzahl wen wundert's mehr als
20 sexualpartner wären verwerflich und
wer unter 10 hätte sei unerfahren also
vor ein paar jahren hätte man ganz
andere antworten erhalten
zitat wir sind alle sehr viel toleranter
und abenteuerliche geworden wenn wir
diese umfrage vor zehn jahren gestellt
hätten hätten männer mit deutlich
weniger sexualpartner bei frauen
gerechnet so ein sprecher von eliten
konter slot com gegenüber dem
intendanten die fragen die sich mir
stellen ist dann tatsächlich direkt
sexuell unerfahren wenn man weniger als
zehn sexualpartner hatte hat das
wirklich was mit der anzahl der partner
zu tun vielleicht sollte man auch daran
denken dass user einer dating seite eben
auch sexuell aktiver und vielleicht auch
ein wenig experimentierfreudiger sind
als der durchschnitt außerdem kommt es
ja auch darauf an was man so im bett
treibt was haltet ihr davon was sagt ihr
zur sexualpartner studie macht das sinn
gibt es überhaupt irgendwelche unter
oder obergrenzen ab in die kommentare
damit abonniert den kanal ist kostenlos
lasst bitte ein like da teilt das video
auf twitter oder facebook und ja bis
dann bleibt dran und das heißt das
nächste video gruppen
das garantiert spannend